battlefield 4 CTE is out with two new
maps to test getting the darkness
treatment this time is Golmud railway
and Zavod 311 to catch those up not in
the know the community test environment
is dice la is continuing experimental
development of battlefield for one of
their initiatives is the night maps
project and another is the community map
building project I'd like to come out on
record as saying don't buy battlefield 4
premium just to play CTE but if you
already own premium for PC then check
out some of these fun concept maps what
is nighttime bring to Golmud railway and
Zavod 311 Golmud railway for starters
was already a great armor map with lots
of destructions ground deformation and
the ability to get caught out in the
open with no good options speaking of
getting caught in the open one of the
things still not working with a night
maps project in my mind is the darkness
itself not hiding players well enough
unlike the more dense urban night map
infiltration of shanghai on Golmud a
player with a night scope or just a good
pair of eyeballs can still spot enemies
running through the darkness at great
distances the next iteration still needs
some kind of shroud of Darkness kind of
how battlefield 2 used to hide bad draw
distance with fog without that players
who cranked up their brightness and
gamma settings will always hold an
advantage the game's classic mode that
turns off 3d spotting and health regen
is still doing more for the night
concept than the night itself zabba 311
is a little more diverse as a night map
than goleman the terrain is a lot more
variety with thin forest rolling hills a
small destructible town bunkers and the
two main factories battles leave most of
the structures on the map totally blown
out and it's still a pleasure to compare
the map before and after matches the
biggest difference on zavod regarding
night seems to be in helicopter piloting
helicopters can actually move far enough
fast enough to vanish into the dark that
doesn't really get around the fact that
surface-to-air missiles in battlefield 4
pretty much destroy a helicopter play
but it does help more of your
engagements on zaphod will be surprise
encounters so don't forget to pack your
night scopes one thing being showcased
well by night maps are just explosions
in general tracer rounds grenades and
other detonations look better than ever
night also headlights are now in play
and can be used to blind opponents
overall I'm still happy to drop in on
CTE every once in a while and see what
ideas dice la are cooking but i'll
probably be spending most of my time in
valve of hardline which launches next
week and star wars battlefront around
wintertime CTE seems to continue to
target battlefield 4 fans who may be put
off by hard lines cops and robbers
infantry focus gameplay and I imagine
dice la will continue to put their time
and effort into it to hold those fans
over into a battlefield 5 thanks for
watching and we'll see you soon in
battlefield hardline